what's up guys this is chris kohler with
wired com we're here at the years of war
two event with Cliff Bleszinski who is
the design director at Epic Games now
cliff I was reading on the internet that
years of war tube is bigger and better
and also more badass than every other
gears of war game put together combined
well considering that there is only one
gears of war game you know I don't know
how much that says but we're basically
just saying that the game it's a more
epic scale but it's also more intimate
there's a larger scale of battle when
you're going through the campaign
there's tons of shoppers that are
fighting the flying Reavers and you're
all these derek trucks and the locations
you go to bury from the depths of the
underground all the way to like the
highest snow-capped peak in the planet
but also there's more executions there's
more of a personal story there's more
in-your-face actions so its bigger but
it's also more intimate so a lot of the
focus of the game is in the two-player
co-op mode is that it really you know
big thing that you're working on right
now we're doing a two-player cooperative
in the main campaign and then we have a
new mode called horde which is up to
five players cooperative in which
basically five guys get together and
deal with wave after wave of
increasingly difficult locust it's a lot
of fun so kind of like a smash TV meets
geometry wars yeah it's really
interesting that sounds like an
old-school arcade style game so you
pretty much is you play until you die
right I mean we're looking at probably
about 50 waves and the first person that
hits 50 waves gets a cookie from me
because in the office we're having a
hard time testing it because we can only
get to like wave 26 so we're going to
bring in some ringers before we ship to
make sure it's actually physically
possible to get to wave 50 so you're
also announcing a couple other things
about the single player game like things
that you can ride on maybe yeah we've
been up bugged a lot about vehicles
because everyone loves vehicles and we
do have the Centaur which is our tank
it's kind of like a monster truck meets
a tank and then we've confirmed here at
e3 that you can ride the broom at
just kind of large gears creature it's
like three four stories tall big guns on
it and then also we slipped a little
detail then you get to ride the Reavers
at one point the campaign you're kind of
those like flying squid-like creatures
so we have several vehicular sections of
the game no entertainment intimate
violence is what we're going for
anything else want to tell us about
gears of war two I just think we're
gonna really surprise people with the
sheer scope of the campaign mode and I
think they're really gonna enjoy getting
to know who these guys aren't Delta
Squad a little bit better and I think
they're going to really enjoy playing
the multiplayer the party system and
kind of you know really digging in with
all the new game modes and all the new
multiplayer maps we have it's really a
complete wonderful package well cliff
thanks a lot for being here I know I'm
looking forward to it I know everybody's
pretty much going to buy it so thanks
for having that thank you ah the power
glove if you weren't a child in the late
80s you have no idea why we all wanted
one of these this was back during what
we now have to refer to as nintendo's
first ride at the top of the video game
industry when they were so powerful that
they could get small children to sit in
the theater and watch a 90 minute
advertisement for their products yes I'm
talking about the wizard
Powerglove
I loved our glove it's so bad Oh Lucas
Barton we all wanted to be you and have
a power glove I mean God look what this
thing did you could actually control a
video game it's by moving your hand in
the air this was the future this was
lawnmower man this was virtual reality
right here in 1989 and when Mattel
released the power glove that holiday
season it flew off the shelves so how
did this thing work well the power glove
was based on virtual reality glove input
devices that at the time were being used
by places like Oh NASA and MIT except
for they cost about ten thousand dollars
so uh patel had to do was to create
something that was actually consumer
level cheap about a hundred bucks and so
the way that it calculates the
positioning of the glove in space is
using ultrasonic receivers aka a bunch
of really cheap microphones that's
what's attached to the TV in back of me
the power glove itself had ultrasound
emitters aka really cheap speakers that
would send out those sort of ultrasonic
you know beeps that humans can't hear
but drives dogs crazy and then the
sensors on the TV the reason that
there's three of them they would pick up
the beep and then they would use a
formula to triangulate where the sound
was coming from and then it would know
the position of the glove in space
meanwhile inside each of the fingers of
the glove were strips of conductive ink
you can see it right there basically
this is what they would use to print
circuit boards now a problem with
conductive ink is that when you bend
conductive ink it changes the way that
it conducts electricity this was perfect
for the power glove because these these
strips basically as you bent your
fingers would send signals back to the
glove letting you know that your fingers
were bent and so to move a character up
down left and right you'd move the glove
like this and then you'd actually just
bend your fingers to hit the a and B
buttons how did it work well it was
pretty much horrible okay Baker so I'm
gonna start you off with something nice
and easy super mario brothers everybody
knows super mario brothers right so
you're going to hold hold your hand you
we're going to Center you press the
center button so that's your center
right here so if you move your hand
right you're going to start running to
the right move it up a little bit you're
hitting down and right okay now you're
hitting up and oh yeah there we go okay
all right Mario is running yeah and
you're just gonna you're just gonna
squeeze your thumb just like that it's
gonna make you that's gonna make you
jump you're not you're not hitting right
though you know hit you eat no no no
that's left you got to go right there
little split seconds where it feels like
I'm actually controlling the movement oh
yeah it's gone well I love how you're I
love how you're running backwards
because because of the you're holding
down and right at the same time which
makes Mario run backwards it's too but
no move your hand more to the right more
to the right so you got to use the you
gotta use a little LCD things that's
gonna show you gotta jump you gotta jump
you gotta flex your thumb so what do you
think of the power glove so far uh I
wish it worked but it looks really cool
you